So whenever I tell people
I’m an Arctic scientist,
the first thing that they always ask me
is: How cold is it up there?
(Laughter)
And yeah, the Arctic can get pretty cold.
Trust me when I tell you
that working outside at -40 degrees
is really, really challenging.
But in the summer of 2019,
it was anything but cold.
So that summer I was working
with my research team
in Alaska’s Yukon Kuskokwim Delta
on the traditional lands
of the Yup’ik and Cup’ik people.
And we were up there
hauling hundreds of pounds of equipment
across the tundra in the middle
of a record-breaking heatwave.
It was 90 degrees Fahrenheit.
There was no breeze,
nowhere to go for a shade
and seemingly endless miles of tundra
as far as my eyes could see.
To make matters worse,
the land had drastically changed
since we had been here
just one year before.
The ground was sinking
and it was cracking.
In places, it was literally
collapsing beneath my feet.
I’ve been working in the Arctic
for more than a decade,
and I had never seen changes happening
this rapidly ever before.
The changes we saw were remarkable,
and they were also really concerning.
But we were there  to measure changes
that we couldn’t see.
We were there to fill a major gap
in our understanding
of how the changing Arctic
is impacting the Earth’s climate.
So we were installing what’s called
an “eddy covariance tower,”
which is a series of instruments
that measures the exchange
of greenhouse gases,
like carbon dioxide and methane,
between the land and the atmosphere.
It’s essentially like measuring
the Earth’s breath.
And so the reason
the land around us was collapsing
is because the once permanently
frozen ground called permafrost
was starting to thaw.
And once it thaws,
that collapsing ground
can drastically alter
the vast expanse of the Arctic’s
tundra and boreal forest,
and it can also threaten
the homes and lifeways
of Arctic residents.
Just imagine if the ground
beneath your home
suddenly started to sink.
That's what's happening
across the Arctic.
But thawing permafrost
also threatens everyone on the planet
because it stores a massive amount
of ancient frozen carbon.
And when that carbon thaws,
it can be released into the atmosphere
as greenhouse gases,
leading to more warming and more thaw.
So let me place the magnitude
of this problem in perspective for you.
By the end of this century,
greenhouse gas emissions
from thawing permafrost
may be on par with some of the world’s
leading greenhouse-gas-emitting nations,
perhaps as large as or larger
than emissions from the United States,
the second-largest greenhouse-gas-emitting
country in the world.
And you know, I want to point out,
this is not a new phenomena.
Arctic residents and scientists
have been observing
permafrost thaw now for decades.
But the scale of the research
hasn’t been sufficient
to meet this enormous challenge.
Because no one country is directly
responsible for permafrost thaw,
no single nation has taken
responsibility for fully monitoring
and tracking its impact across the Arctic.
And this is not a case
where ignorance is bliss,
because what doesn't get measured
doesn't get accounted for.
Because we can’t put a precise number
on permafrost emissions,
policymakers are essentially
excluding them,
setting global emissions targets
that are wholly insufficient
to protect us from catastrophic
climate change.
Ignoring permafrost
is essentially like leaving a major
greenhouse-gas-emitting country,
like the United States,
out of global climate negotiations,
which is not a good idea.
What we need to know is where
permafrost is thawing across the Arctic
and how fast,
what that means in terms
of greenhouse gas emissions
and how that will impact our climate
in 10, 50 or 100 years from now.
Answering these questions requires
a massive and integrated effort
at a scale that matches
the enormity of this problem.
Thankfully, we have a plan.
Through an ambitious new initiative
called Permafrost Pathways,
we’ve formed a coalition
of Arctic residents and scientists,
Indigenous knowledge-holders
and Arctic and climate policy influencers
to tackle this problem
with the urgency it deserves.
Recognizing that we cannot continue
on our current climate trajectory,
we’ve brought this team
together to think big
and to act boldly
and to work across boundaries
to take us on a new pathway forward.
So to get started,
the first thing that we need to do
is to actually measure
greenhouse gas emissions
across the entire Arctic.
Currently there are only a handful
of monitoring towers across the Arctic
that run year round
and that measure
both important greenhouse gases,
carbon dioxide and methane.
So we’re working with a team
of international scientific experts
to strategically identify
and fill these monitoring gaps
by installing new equipment
across the Arctic
in remote locations where monitoring
currently doesn’t exist.
We believe that by installing
just 10 new monitoring sites,
we can drastically improve
our estimates of permafrost emissions,
which will remove a major barrier
to their incorporation
into the global climate policy.
And we’re coupling
this on-the-ground monitoring
with high-resolution
satellite observations
and advanced computer modeling
so that we can track
the changing Arctic in near real-time
and accurately project
permafrost emissions into the future.
But state-of-the-art science
just isn’t enough.
We need to make sure
that permafrost emissions are counted
when setting global emissions targets,
because each year that we fail
to account for permafrost is another year
that we become unwittingly locked-in
to more severe climate warming.
So we’re working
with leading policy experts
to bring this new knowledge
to the table with the decision-makers
at the highest level
to make sure that global climate policy
is accounting for permafrost
and aiming for the right targets.
But the truth is,
even with the most
ambitious climate action,
some permafrost is going to thaw --
that’s already happening.
Right now across the Arctic,
people are having to make
extremely difficult decisions
about where and how to live
in order to protect
themselves and their families
from the hazards of climate change.
So we’re working with our team members
and our partners who live on permafrost
to bring these monitoring
and modeling tools
to assess the current and future impacts
of permafrost thaw on Arctic communities,
and to co-create adaptation plans
that protect and respect the health,
well-being
and human rights of Arctic residents.
These are the gaps we plan to fill.
Painting a picture of the Arctic
that we have never
been able to see before,
and recognizing that ultimately,
the climate crisis
is a human rights crisis,
and it’s one that’s already underway.
But through these actions
that we take now,
we can greatly reduce future harm
and take us on a more just
and equitable journey.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)